if you have ever found your guitar
difficult to play You're Not Alone In
fact you might just need a guitar setup
when a guitar's action is too high it's
pretty much impossible to play so action
is the height of the strings above the
fretboard thankfully this type of thing
can be adjusted and in this video we're
going to teach you with the help of our
pro-luth your friend Marshall brene how
to do a guitar setup at home
so Marshall lots of people find their
guitars difficult to play but don't even
realize that they can have it improved
what type of things do you do when
someone takes their guitar to you and
says hey make this easier to play the
first thing I look at is the height of
the string above the first fret
when this is depressed it should be the
same height over here so if it's more
than that it's going to be hard to play
and most Factory instruments are set up
difficult to play because they don't
want them to buzz well the next step I
look at the Saddle the saddle is this
white piece of material here usually
bone on cheaper guitars this usually
some type of synthetic material like
plastic and this can come out and you
can also change the size of it which
changes the strings on the bridge side
that's right and so I will also look and
see how much saddle is left to go down
beyond that we're talking major surgery
so if your guitar doesn't pass this
criteria or this criteria I don't advise
going any further on your own then you
need a marshall but playability is so
important and if you watch our video
that Marshall and I did comparing
guitars blindfolded you'll really get a
sense of how important playability is in
fact at some point I picked a guitar
which was very playable thanks to the
work that Marshall did on it which was
only 300 over a guitar which cost
thousands of dollars which was badly in
need of a setup because I felt it
fighting me so it's the most important
thing the playability and a setup is
what can get you to have that beautiful
easy to play guitar that's right you
don't need a fifteen thousand dollar
guitar to play well you just need a good
setup so since playability is so
important in this video Marshall has
generously offered to show us what we
can all do at home using common
household tools to make your guitar more
playable so should we go to the shop
yeah let's go all right
you've seen a lot of Brandon's videos on
this guitar and he's played beautifully
but I think I can make this better first
things first I'm looking at the knot I'm
looking at the Saddle I want to see kind
of How High the action is as a whole so
I'm seeing with these gut strings which
are exceptionally delicate that there's
a little bit of a sharp edge on this nut
so what I'm going to want to do is round
that over if need be and then from there
I'm looking at the action so on the
sixth string three and three quarters
and then on the first string is
one two and three quarters so to the top
of the Fret to the underside of the
string I think we can get this down
because
I'm looking down the neck and it's got a
good curvature you don't ever want to
see a neck that's dead straight so what
I'm seeing is I can take down the saddle
a little bit and I can adjust the knot
to the string each string to make sure
that it fits properly and then once I do
that I'm going to polish this up and
make sure that this string doesn't
continue to fray this is actually
causing a very moderate amount of
falseness over the entire length of the
string so it may not be noticeable but
it's there so I'm going to just take
down the the strings
all right so now that the strings are
completely loose I should be able to
slip
the saddle right out
these should never ever be glued in if
you glue in a saddle I'm coming for you
so I want to lower the action a little
bit use a hard service we're going to
take some 120 grit sandpaper and we're
just going to hold it down what we're
gonna do is very carefully make sure
that saddle is
balanced across the bottom and
since I want to lower the base side of
this a little bit more
I'm gonna
grab it on the base side
and just very carefully
stand back and forth in order to remove
the material now this material actually
does come off fairly quickly so be
careful we're going to just continue
sanding through
this saddle a bit we don't want to take
off too terribly much because it's
pretty close and that's all that we need
now we also want to make sure that the
bottom surface is square to each Edge
because if it's at this angle or at this
angle too much
it's not going to make good contact with
the bottom of the saddle slot so we're
going to give this a try we took off
probably about a little bit over a
quarter of a millimeter which means
it'll bring it down about a tenth here
which will make it noticeably easier to
play
so we're going to just take that
slide it back in we'll give this a
little quick measure yeah that took it
down to about 3.3 millimeters on the
base string so that'll be a lot nicer
now this guitar I don't feel like it
needs any adjustment at the nut but if
it's too high again you could do the
same technique
or if you've got a hobbyist set of files
like this you can use one of these to
very carefully work the nut very very
carefully this is a hobbyist file
and it's got a nice grit on this corner
which is what you want to use so what
I'm doing right now is I'm looking at
the very corner of the the nut where it
should be vibrating from and I'm
actually seeing that it's rounded this
way which a lot of companies like to do
because it looks it's very very nice but
what it doesn't do is go give a good
Edge for the string to vibrate from so
you're actually losing sound if those
are too rounded over and you have a very
Instinct Edge
for the string to roll on so again you
can see right here it's vibrating from
here not here and I'm not lowering the
front of the slot at all I'm just
crisping up that edge seeing it has a
more distinct place to vibrate from
I'm not putting a whole lot of pressure
onto it I'm just putting enough to make
sure that it stays engaged okay so now
that this has been adjusted I'm going to
want to polish this
so in order to do that
I am going to employ the use of a string
and a little bit of car polish we're
just going to put a little tiny drop so
you're going to get your little inner
shoe shine and going
and
shoe shine this this way it's taking
away any and all rough edges and again
this is a smiled abrasive so you don't
want to do this too terribly much and
what this is going to do is Polish the
inside of that slot so that way we can
remove any of these sharp edges that are
cutting Brandon's very expensive gut
strings so that's what you're going to
do if your nut is too high to the first
fret you want to lower the slots down
and that is only to the first fret it's
not going to change anything Downstream
on the guitar so if your nut is too low
and you're constantly buzzing at your
first string what you want to do
is to get a luthier approved business
card you can only use a luthier approved
business card and what you're going to
do
typically it's the fifth and sixth
string that are going to be too low so
you're going to just want to bring it up
ever so slightly and believe it or not
one of these normal business cards is
just the right thickness most of the
time to get things taken care of so I
like to use this ultra thin super glue
for doing this operation but you don't
have to go out and buy this you can use
some regular old wood glue or if you're
feeling very creative and arts and
craftsy you can just cut out a piece of
this and stick it under there it's not
going to affect the sound at all I can
promise you so normally I'm just going
to glue this in and then I use a knife
to cut it out I suggest just cutting it
apart and putting one or two pieces in
if you get past two pieces of shim
material come see me or another luthier
who knows what they're doing okay after
that it starts to get ridiculous so yes
you can put a shim under here you can
put a shim under here
99.999 times out of 100 you're not going
to hear the difference I can't and I
suppose we've established it I've got
okay ears you could always raise the
action a little bit you can always drop
the action a little bit don't go
overboard a little piece of paper will
do way more than you think so at this
point all we have to do is get
the nut back on you have to make sure
that it's like a ramp going to the front
and likewise with the saddle that it's a
ramp going to the front
you don't want it to be backwards like
this because then I get people calling
me saying I have an intonation issue and
it's because they put the knot on
backwards or the saddle or both so make
sure that it's going the right way at
this point in time this is when I highly
recommend putting a drop of three in one
oil onto your guitar what we're gonna do
is we're going to put a drop of oil
right where the worm meets the gear just
one
drop on every roller once you have that
on you'll notice that your tuning
machines run a lot smoother and you've
just increased the lifespan of your
tuning machines by a long time
you'd be amazed at how many tuning
machines wear out prematurely because
they don't have
a drop of oil put on them once a year
and at that point your guitar is done
that's the most home setup that I would
recommend doing beyond that
bring it by if you want to clean it up
just use a little bit of water and a
cotton towel it's that simple no waxes
no polishes no moisturizers rejuvenators
none of that that's all going to make my
job harder if you ever have to bring it
in Marshfield thanks so much for being
so generous and helping out all of my
YouTube followers and showing them how
they can do this at home this has been
super helpful oh you're welcome anytime
I'm happy to help and if any of you have
any questions
feel free to reach out and contact me
off of my website and for 500 off use
promo code Brandon that's good for any
new guitar and you know I'll talk you
through this if you have any questions
thanks Marshall thanks Brandon
[Music]